[Música]
José navega en el río nuchiño que divide
las provincias de Napo y pastaza en la
amazonía ecuatoriana al este del país es
miembro de la comunidad conipade dentro
del pueblo guaraní
es coordinador de un equipo de monitores
que se encarga de rastrear amenazas como
deforestación o contaminación de
petroleras en la selva reportamos lo que
es así deforestación temas de casa y
pesca porque muchas ocasiones antes
anteriormente así hace año atrás ha
habido mucha deforestación lo hacen con
la ayuda de una aplicación o dk Este
programa funciona sin Internet pero con
ubicación satelitales de tal manera que
los monitores pueden hacer reportes in
situ de las amenazas con imágenes Aunque
el equipo de monitoreo lleva tan solo 8
meses José asegura que la tala ha
disminuido y esto genera esperanzas en
el futuro de aquí 20 años queremos tener
nuestro árbol el agua así tener algo que
sea que sea natural y las futuras
generaciones que viene ellos puedan
seguir viendo como nosotros vemos así
pescados así animales así todo en las
últimas décadas la deforestación por
madereros petroleras o cultivos y otras
amenazas a replegado a los guaraníes en
su territorio ancestral Este programa de
monitoreo es impulsado mediante
cooperación internacional con apoyo de
organizaciones como la agencia francesa
de desarrollo para ayudar a proteger la
selva amazónica y a sus habitantes
este proyecto es muy interesante porque
intervienen en diferentes niveles de la
autonomización y de la gestión del
pueblo indígena de su propio territorio
por un lado permite controlar mejor el
territorio y al mismo tiempo prever Los
ejes de desarrollo
la fundación local eco ciencia trabaja
junto a la afd en el proyecto Lleva años
ayudando a monitorear el impacto de
amenazas externas al territorio guaraní
Lizeth es una de ellas ha capacitado a
monitores de la selva como José el
proyecto Busca que los reportes de
agresiones al ambiente no sólo queden
documentados sino que ayuden a crear
estadísticas y a conocer los puntos del
territorio donde se presentan más
amenazas y cuáles de estas son las más
recurrentes así estos conocimientos
también llegan rápidamente a las
autoridades indígenas esta información
nos ayuda a poder dirigir a nosotros el
trabajo como técnicos de Hacia dónde se
deben de poner las principales miradas y
a tener conclusiones rápidas de que es
lo que está pasando en el territorio
pero sobre todo para que sean los
líderes quienes a través del
conocimiento de lo que ocurre Y dónde
puedan tomar mejores decisiones las
autoridades locales son las que deciden
que castigos aplicar a quienes vulneran
la selva toman acciones de prevención y
también pueden acudir a instancias más
altas como el Ministerio de ambiente y
para nuestro país es importante el que
se reconozca primero que también los
indígenas pueden aportar
con monitoreo con con un trabajo en
campo que esto es muy difícil que lo
puedan realizar instituciones como el
Ministerio del ambiente que no pueden
estar todo el tiempo en el territorio el
proyecto en el que cooperan ecociencia y
la agencia francesa de desarrollo
también fomenta actividades económicas
sostenibles como cultivos de cacao Yuca
o bambú Lily Río Frío ayuda en la
capacitación de estos cultivos una
necesidad que surgió en 2010 cuando las
mujeres guaurani comenzaron a notar que
la proteína necesaria para alimentar a
sus familias escaseado antes los hombres
la conseguían con la casa o la pesca
pero ya no es posible por la degradación
de los bosques y la biodiversidad cada
vez era más distante conseguir este tipo
de proteína y esto amenazó la seguridad
alimentaria de estas familias es así
como las mujeres de las comunidades se
organizan y buscan apoyo cultivos como
el cacao restan presión a los bosques y
permiten no solo parar la tala de
árboles sino reactivar los terrenos
Sergio ha sido uno de los líderes
locales que se ha capacitado en la
producción de cacao mientras tiene su
producto de cacao
vende su cacao y tiene su ingreso para
ayudar para sus hijos y también para
sustento de la familia a raíz de la
producción de estos cultivos la
comunidad también ha creado un centro de
acopio liderado por mujeres Nancy de la
comunidad es una de ellas ha sido muy
importante como mujer tener
donde que otras mujeres vienen a vender
y estar ahí ayudando para que mejoren
su calidad de Vida en el centro de
acopio reciben el cacao que producen
otras 60 mujeres además de otros
miembros de la comunidad actualmente
reúnen en mil libras al mes
aquí el cacao pasa por varias fases de
fermentación luego es secado antes de
ser vendido a comerciantes el trabajo
ayuda a que las familias tengan más
ingresos pero al mismo tiempo Cuida la
selva cuidamos el bosque a través que
vendemos el cacao vendemos cacao no
estamos talando todo árbol
ahora trabajan junto a la cooperación
internacional para certificar el cacao
con sellos de calidad y poder
comercializarlo a mejor precio en los
mercados orgullosa de su trabajo Nancy
Espera que la fundación siga dando
trabajo a las siguientes generaciones de
mujeres y aportando recursos a la
comunidad y que esta siga teniendo un
territorio sano y fructífero en el que
crecer
[Aplausos]